welcome to fears to Fathom this is
episode 3 in an episodic series of scary
horror goodness let's see and show him
some of the scary horror goodness from
before
oh my God
oh hello hi who's in there oh oh God
what see told you scary horror goodness
the first of this actually scared the
crap out of me
and this is the Carson house
so if you remember the last one was
something about uh getting stranded on
the highway and then going to a hotel
and the first one was also a house so I
don't know if this is a return to form
or whatever my name is Noah I'm a 28
year old male from the Midwest I have no
idea why I'm sending this but I hope my
story can be a lesson this happened to
me when I was 18. but I remember this
incident like yesterday as the trauma
dictated a major part of my life for a
little background my dad was a realtor
and almost always became friends with
his clients one day he came home and
pitched me a small job offer for the
weekend one of his old clients was going
away for a few days and needed somebody
that he could trust to watch over his
house the man worked as a CEO at a local
media company that told me the man would
pay me a hundred dollars just to watch
the house and do some basic chores I
accepted the offer as I had nothing
interesting going on for the weekend
besides I thought I could use the time
to get my schoolwork done plus I wasn't
picky where my pocket money came from
my dad drove me to the house
oh
this isn't a house
this isn't a house at all but this this
wait a minute wasn't that the intro to
episode one wait a minute that doesn't
sound right
wait no
did that just play the episode intro at
intro depth but
I'm in a laundromat I don't know if this
is where I'm supposed to be
actually it's definitely where I'm
supposed to be because it didn't work
before
dot dot dot
dot dot dot dot
why would the why would I go where only
employees may go all right whatever no
need to tell me twice about going into a
dark scary oh the back rooms the
macaroons
the back rooms
I don't know why I ended up back here
but this is strangely an empty void with
nothing but what I'm dead
I'm dead
I'm drugged
I've been drunk here
I am seeing the walls Mills I'm high
wow
nice basket
shift to Sprint do I need this Sprint
though in case of equipment failure
please and I don't know where to go
[Music]
I don't even feel like Sprint Amazon
Sprint no I'm not
responsible for lost items
hey
what are you doing down here
which one are you high are you blasted
you blow
bleach
it's not my name I guess where did you
put it
where did I put what [__]
where is the bleach I need bleach
I don't even know what you're talking
about I said I need bleach
Noah
now time's over we're here we're here
you said you could do this
Wake Up Now wake up Noah Noah wake up
ah that intro was the intro to this game
hello
you still think you can do this
I got it
Roy called and said the key should be
under the fake rock got it he said it's
in the backyard got it and like I said
keep the doors locked and don't open the
door for anyone I heard that the first
time Dad okay now get your ass to work I
hope you know I'm only in it for the
snacks
I love you Dad God never say never say
first
all right bye whatever
it was a nice neighborhood
had to get the key from the backyard
where else would it be
whoa hey what's up car
this does look a lot like the
[Music]
first episode
but it's different but it's but it's
kind of different though a flower
but I don't remember the freaking
laundromat
boy boy
hi boy thank you for not mauling me
oh my goodness okay
why
oh
I thought I thought for a second that
okay I definitely don't remember there
being a dog in the last one so this must
seem
but I can't see anything cause it's dork
it's really dark
I don't see no fake rock I don't even
see a rock
who's moaning I just got here cut the
ambons
hey Bob what's going on um you looking
to get inside I don't know good dog good
home is that a rock
Bud where are you going
all right Alexian fast forward Till I
Find The Rock
oh
[Music]
how could anybody have seen that okay
whatever it's fine
I got a fake rock key key
am I am I am I
familiar yum
boy
where'd you go boy I had to pee this jar
of Nutella reminded me Bill get out of
here I have to piss
maybe I should lock the door no
no way
too urgent whoa
you vlogging
you're vlogging bro
you vlogging bro
bro you vlogging bro where's the
bathroom
nope
where's the bathroom
where's it got dang oh
anybody there okay anybody there okay
piss Ahoy
piss a horse
wow
Mr Carson was good
you're right he wasn't but God damn look
at me closing both Lids before I flushed
I'm so polite no poop articles getting
in the air here whoa
hello
I'm honestly jealous of Ava whoa thanks
for taking the job or just at the
weirdest dream ever huh
I was totally bonking out on some soap
suds you know
come on come on I was totally bonking
out oh it's Roy got this contact oh what
oh that's my book no problem Mr Carson
my pleasure really haha he's my dad you
ever Bonk out on some soap suds all
right
well
wow I recognize that Roy Carson I
wouldn't have asked for any of one if it
wasn't for Zeke Zeke
boy's been a little sick lately
well I'll take care of them in the house
now that I'm here you have nothing to
worry about Mr Carson where's your booze
where's your soap suds where's your soap
sets Okay soap sounds around here
you soaping bro you soaping you straight
up soaping so what am I oh three you're
a lifesaver kid speaking of him I wanted
to remind you it's his dinner time if
you could get him his dog food from the
basement right on it
on it
I'm on it
it was a little too dark yep
[Music]
no good
no food
almost forgot I apologize the lights out
you can grab the flashlight okay
yep
yep from the storage room where upstairs
got it
where's the stairs
there's the stairs
realize this house was way bigger than
ours
jealousy flared inside my breast as in
my chest not anything else what's the
storage room why why do you have a
storage room
why do you have a whole room
anybody out there
is that just the Ambiance being weird or
is that
something I should worry about also is
this the storage room I have no idea I
can't see no such thing as light
switches around here
oh
[Music]
car's coming no it's not
huh
I think the reason that Mr Carson's
bedroom had this weird smell of wet
clothes
why
did someone
have went close in there was someone wet
in there
I think the reason this looks familiar
because the same house from Red snow or
whatever it was storage room
storage room oh
weird Mr Carson's office looked like a
good spot I could sit down and work at
does it
does it no where is the storage room
where is the flashlight
how many rooms you get this feels like
the storage room I don't know why
seems like it would be
but I can't see dick
anywhere
all right
I don't like the implications of this
door
I don't like the implications of that at
all
rail was too lazy to model
okay I'm gonna just this is the only
other place I haven't been
is this the storage room
oh
I can't see [__] oh oh where am I it's
dork
his dork why can't I not have any
flashlights how am I see how am I this
stupid how am I this stupid
am I dumb
oh
wait but I haven't
I remember I was doing but I haven't
gotten the flashlight but but but I
didn't but I didn't but I didn't but but
I didn't okay whatever
wait no I was doing calculus that night
you know what I'm just gonna do the
calculus
I did have school work to do but I
wasn't feeling it at the time
okay I don't feel like it at the time
never mind I need to find a flash light
you'd think that it would be glowing or
sparking or something silly like that
something crazy okay turning on a mode
of my monitor to help me see better oh
wow I still can't see [__]
oh my God
are you kidding me okay I found the
flashlight everybody I did it so now I
can find the dog food and I can get this
boy his treats that he deserves wow this
is a big basement
you got food down here
you got food is that food that dog food
no Bubba I need dog food though
is that dog food
it's a can
canned dog food I like it
holy puppy puppy
who's a good boy do I need to open this
I had opened again of course that's my
bad that's my bad that makes a lot of
sense that that I I would I would assume
that that would be the case
all right everybody got a can opener can
openy
can open E can openy
canopy
wow that was cool all right Bubba or a
good boy is your name boy
is your name boy
hmm here's some Bubble Boy
nice you eat up good boy best dog you
got that right
all right so now that that's done I
gotta get some homework done
I'm sure nothing strange is filmed here
just gonna close that oh
Hey kid Ern from Walter you're a
computer whiz huh I have a favor to ask
my computer's been acting weird lately
and my whole security system is tied to
it oh you got a whole security system
set up there
well I'll head up I guess I'm pretty
sure that's where I need to go
to lose
anybody out there
[Music]
have a lot of expensive equipments
laying around don't want anything
happening to it well that sounds pretty
good to me
thanks kid oh I'll look at your computer
I'm looking at the computer what do we
got here
uh uh Roy
um what's your password
uh password
got any soap sets
meow meow cat
oh
Alec Carson
Ali ale Carson
5387 okay I guess
oh eight three seven I forget what the
last few I think it's 837.
oh five three eight seven
okay I did it I solved the puzzle
oh goodness egg egg egg egg egg
yeah
okay
guess the
guide to being a what
guide to being a what better person oh
[Music]
um
that's a good rule
[Music]
being rude will discur
Matt
sorry it appears that something's wrong
with the broadcast what do you mean this
is a video you made
in the meantime enjoy some happy images
what Oh that's oh that's a good one
step oh step two remain calm in any
conversation
[Music]
now even though what he said was
controversial did you stay calm
the secret to being calm is to not let
your feelings interfere with the
conversation
being calm makes you a better person
[Music]
that's all we effort to thank you
glad I looked that what do you got here
what do you got here free limited wow
your children catch colds your computer
catches wow
I want full protection
yeah
okay performed full scan
yes remove
Trojan huh oh easy
okay does it work uh oh there we go well
that's nice
it's nice nice nice
man weird how you have it everywhere
oh Pokey
[Music]
okey dokey then seems all good to me
your computer is A-Okay tell that to my
kid but thanks I'll drop you a nice tip
when I get back oh it was a drug I told
him apparently okay
Evelyn
oh what was it about weird reminds me of
cooking on with Jeffrey on channel 10
last night by the way the rerun must be
on right now you gotta watch it with me
wait that place got a TV yeah hold on
you guys soap suds you want to Bonk out
you want a bunker you'll be bonking
always be bonking
ABP
so what's on TV I kind of missed the
point of that
peekaboo I see you wow
I'm Jeffrey
and today we are cooking
food it's my favorite dish super
enjoyable
mm-hmm nothing that just looked
delicious
so first we are going to gently pour the
Cat Board onto this conveniently placed
end on a stove
okay now while that's cooking
work on an appetizer
I will be preparing what's known as the
piece of cardboard dipped in milk we
will need a piece of cardboard a glass
and some milk
to start we poured the milk into the
glass
next we dip the cardboard into the
middle do you think you've Roy also I
think you should get the groceries
before it gets too dark outside there's
some oh
I'm I'm doing this
why do I do this
okay I guess I'll go get the groceries
it's time to eat everybody
um
[Music]
got too many hands to handle
I'll take them
gotta run dudes on my ass I gotta get
groceries uh I don't know why I gotta
get groceries it's part of my job okay
nightstand what nightstand
nightstand is in by your bed nightstand
what else you got by your nightstand
but I'm missing the best part
how many hands you got
okay
I got a wad of cash
[Music]
for your trouble get something for
yourself as well it's on the house okay
you got it
where does this store
where's the store
anybody seen a store around here
you could take Alex bike it's outside
the garage okay
whatever
whatever how much hand you got me
got me
oh I'm actually riding it I thought it
would be like a cutscene to the
more than a little bizarre
I am slightly confused I don't know
where the grocery is oh never mind I'm
blacking out
it's 9 22 p.m for those of you who
didn't know
oh
[Applause]
okay there are other reasons I could
have died tonight excuse me I'm looking
for something pardon me cause me
ah what do I need what's on my list I'm
am
all right we
Branch okay
I can't select anything until I get off
is that how this is gonna be
milk oh I can't get milk hello ma'am
excuse me wow okay you need to build a
more convenient store here it's kind of
a
difficult it's difficult
hello how are you
[Music]
doing good how are you doing good use a
shopping basket all right that's not a
basket that's a basket okay so I need
ketchup
strawberry jelly
oh
is that choco spread it's ready
it's pretty
this ranch ranch ranch ranch
okay Ranch get in the basket
Ranch strawberry jelly choco spread
ketchup honey honey
okay milk and eggs milk and eggs don't
forget milk and eggs okay milk and eggs
are a must but I don't think that means
two milk and eggs so I need Garden peas
and rice
get something for myself how about some
beer
oh hi and speak of the devil Turner and
Andy
bro your girl is here she just left
Eve
what was her name Eve car Eve Eve dude I
said they're not dating anymore oh yeah
he hopped to that other chick so quick I
didn't even realize don't listen to him
but dude she bought tons and tons of
cans I think she's throwing like a party
or something ah you know anything about
it bro she looks way older without the
makeup MILF energy bro ew I think she's
more of like a goth
goth MILF and you guys done anyways dude
what are you up to tonight house sitting
for this guy Carson you mean it Alex he
goes to school with my sister her kid's
a real weirdo especially since his
parents split up
[Music]
old lady all right now can you are you
right behind me a lady could you please
back off
all right see you around I guess wow
what an enlightening conversation can
you oh it's not you
uh possibly why I'm looking for mustard
my son likes mustard but I can't find it
I don't work here but let me get it for
you okay how nice of you I'll be right
over here
where there stopped moving don't move
all right well I don't but I need to
finish all right milk and eggs and peas
I did
where's the rice
milk
eggs
and then
peas Garden pea I don't know where that
is
Garden bees okay I got this and then I'm
gonna get the mustard
should I build this for you
I didn't get all that yes I did
rice rice
Uncle Tony's rice
yes please
mustard ma'am the mustards
yeah it's lit it's bright ma'am ma'am
ma'am ma'am ma'am
ma'am
I I did I I actually did ma'am
down
mom
mustard mustard must
mustard all right whatever
you know what can't help them all
can't help them all
that's a great source of fiber ow
I flipped
can I am I there we go okay try take
four I think
foreign
was still in that store looking for
mustard
she would never find it
never is this a house I can't even
remember
darker I had to pee again and I'm hungry
man when will this torment end what is
floating there
is that my flashlight
what
all right sure
God damn I gotta piss
me with my tiny bladder damn it all can
I set this down at least or do I gotta
piss bags on that's the oven oh time to
piss with my hands full
I hope I don't miss this time
a ghost
it's like a machine gun and a little bit
in oh I'm done
[Music]
Mr Carson's not gonna like that so you
would
so um why what do I
um
but saw something else
[Music]
what do I uh
uh is is this supposed to be obvious
what I'm supposed to do with these this
bag is this supposed to be obvious am I
am I dumb
I'm up
oh
okay I just throw them on the ground
how's that lighting I thought I'd get
some school work done now I thought
right
I'm gonna do that
I'm doing it
school work time
whoa whoa whoa dude you said your car
since you need to see this search up Roy
Carson divorce on the internet right now
well that's interesting
okay Roy Carson divorce
broadcasting claims to be receiving
death threats from the angry fans of his
ex-wife
uh-huh okay
It's Not Unusual for audience to be nosy
about some of the celebrities personal
matters but sometimes it's just too
overbearing we see something similar
with the case of Roy Carson the CEO and
co-founder of BN media after his very
public breakup and divorce with his wife
former actress Alyssa Brown Carson has
allegedly been receiving death threats
from the fans of Alyssa Brown for the
rumored infidelity that underwent within
the said relationship sources say Roy
Carson has had people knocking on his
door to confront him
foreign
hasn't been very vocal about the
situation yet but hunter news is
actively trying
to reach out to her so you the reader
can say I must subscribe
who's uh who's there
oh
that's probably fine
now it's fine why would I be worried
about that
it's fine it's probably fine anyway
hold on
I'll be right there
hello
open wide what
whoa
here
thanks
[Music]
hey this is probably a very strange
request but do you think I can wait
inside until the rain's over
it's probably not very safe to be out
here right now and I forgot my raincoat
at the shop uh
no
oh
I understand
well you have a good day
yeah that wasn't so hard was it
[Music]
all right
well I got pizza
I thought I could watch some TV while
eating
did I order that I don't remember
ordering it
but whatever let's do this
yum
hmm
oh that's weird
piece was nice and hot despite the rain
[Music]
uh-huh Roy yes
who's there look out for some pizzas it
should arrive any minute now enjoy oh
thanks
oh hi
check
are you doing your work
you'll have to spend the night in the
dungeon if you don't
you tell me I've got that radius of two
squared is I'll think about Square
my name is Jack fartas I have been held
hostage by Mr Holland for 37 days he
makes me solve math work until my head
hurts I can't escape
would that be
oh
good night sweet dreams
yum okay I'm getting up didn't get the
last piece stupid who's there
open up
oh flowers
thank you you know didn't know what to
make of it
well they're beautiful
still munching on pizza
then good freaking God hello
what are you doing over there am I still
eating
what
is that gonna haunt me through the rest
of the game now what is happening
please tell me there is not going to be
chewing
for the remainder of my playing of this
game
okay it seems to have finished I was
about to say if that was gonna haunt me
through the rest of this it was going to
be a very different experience
okay well gotta get that work done I
should have closed the TV you're right
I don't know about closing a TV but long
and so I did
because I'm a good boy huh
hey how are you what did you have for
dinner uh
Pizza thanks
I assumed it was a wrong number
it was strange but I dismissed the
thought as a weird canoe incidents and
moved on
homework besides I had a lot of work to
catch up on my engrossment is gross
[Music]
okay
when I was in the middle of my
schoolwork or the power went off how
diligent a student am I
am diligent
okay
are you by yourself why are you keep
ignoring me why are you always so mean
to me you're being very immature right
now fine if you're gonna be like that I
don't need you anyway Todd it's so much
hotter anyways who are you
uh-huh
boy
[Music]
besides him and Annie were the only
people who knew I was house sitting
alone
weird car highlighted over there
boy
puppy
what you doing boy
foreign
[Music]
ly very cold outside boy what's going on
are you parking at
Zeke was acting very weird
huh
okay
I turned the power back on somehow
I could tell that someone had cut the
power off from outside could you it had
to be Turner he was really starting to
piss me off now
train
Turner
whoa
oh well that's concerning
Zeke was acting very weird
you going side boy no no go inside no
no boy you should go inside
foreign
what do you smell with that nose of
yours
okay
whatever you say boy
it's probably fine
you said we'd stay friends Turner this
is not funny I know it's you I know it's
you
what is this always close
oh
oh don't do that to me
[Applause]
[Music]
oh okay so uh
so something's in the house now and
that's not good
[Music]
I just could go
had to get back to my school work for
Monday
had to do it
just had to do it
check the cameras real quick
well that's not good
[Music]
what is that it's probably okay just
gonna do my engrossed
I had a strange good
that might sound stupid now but I just
didn't want to overthink things
motion wait a minute
the door's open
that door's open
I've been Crossing I'm just kind of
engross I'm an ingross I'm engrossing
I'm engrossed
I've been gross
Road oh I'm engrossed
I heard something downstairs did I
did I now
the oven
I swear on my life I didn't turn that
oven on
sure I didn't that's exactly what I I
would want me to think that's
that just plays right into my
plans
uh-huh
[Music]
interesting that that door is open
low-keyed may be very uncomfortable
knowing he was in the house
I had to confront him
I didn't have his contact I could ask
Andy
can you send me Turner's contact ask him
to quit Messing
he's messing with what oh you know
snooping around the house not cool
foreign
question Duty's at my place right now
I attributed it all to my lack of sleep
we were going to the movies but Brady
didn't start pouring so we stuck with
the sleepover I was aware I have
tendency to being overly paranoid the
only logical thing I could do was keep
an eye on the security monitor
yeah I'm gonna do that I'm gonna do that
I'm gonna do that
I'm just gonna do that
I'm gonna do it now I think about I
should have called the cops
nah
that would be paranoid at the time I was
so engrossed in my own thoughts that
the idea never even entered my mind
you're right it didn't
wait a minute
[Music]
um
dude wait did you check out that article
it was Brady you told me about it oh
this is real sketchy
yeah it is a little bit
oh
hello what
whoa oh wait a minute wait wait wait
wait
I thought my heart skip a beat
[Music]
oh
my God
hello
[Music]
foreign
oh
I didn't even trigger it she was right
outside the door to the room I was like
I wasn't even at the right moment oh
[__] I thought my heart would pound
right out of my chest
[Music]
Noah are you in there
really missed you
whatever's happening between us we can
work it out together
there's nothing to talk about
so I've always been nothing but nice to
you
but you always treated me like [__]
you need help Kara I know everything I
know you left me for her this is exactly
why but I love you what about that you
need to leave right now we deserve us
you know I can turn you into the police
for this
do it and I will [__] kill both of
you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
oh my God oh my God what what what did I
do
what did I do what did I do differently
low-key it made me very uncomfortable
what did I do
I was just trying to get back to where I
was what did I do
my God ah good boy Zeke
okay take three four five six seven
eight nine ten
good boy that's a good boy going to bed
good boy you go bed
you go baby bye
okay I'm gonna go down to this
oven again
okay
somehow I'm not dead unlike before I
guess I didn't check on the security
cameras before but whatever
it'd be very uncomfortable doing it was
in the house
oh that's not good
oh
kept staring at the screen and Pierre
horror
man I should have been looking at this
before
[Music]
well that's a problem that's a problem
right there
[Music]
oh boy
oh are you in there
[Applause]
my God
didn't even get there
didn't even get all the way there
how'd you get in here
you need help that's exactly why you
need to leave
[Music]
I know what's going on it's using my
broadcast stream mix as my mic
that it's mixing it up so my mic is
that's why the waveform is moving like
that because the microphone is my audio
so I have to do this this way
luckily for me I can keep this [__]
quiet
doesn't matter how much I yell
Noah
[Music]
thank you
I left the house and ran down the block
my dad called the cops
though by the time they arrived she had
already left the house but I knew where
she lived
Carr was one of the first people I met
on a dating site she was three years
older than me but I found her cute so we
started dating however two months into
our relationship she started doing hard
drugs tried to get her help but she
turned it around on me as if I was
trying to change her one day I had
enough and I had to break it up with her
I told her to leave and never contact me
again she was pissed
she was trying to convince one of the
cops she didn't intend on doing anything
wrong that night but of course the cop
wasn't buying it they reviewed the
footage and it showed everything from
the point of her entry
so the moment she grabbed the kitchen
knife
but the thing that messed with me the
most was the fact that nothing was
stolen from the house turns out she was
heavily under the influence of drug and
alcohol at the time she was arrested and
sentenced for a long while
there you have it
[Music]
I fear those fathoms my fathoms are
feared my fearful fathoms now the thing
about this is I had criticisms about
this game in the first two and in that
time it feels like
it's following still the same kinds of
things
because via kuas there's still
you know what what actually I'll leave
it to that I'll leave it to that it has
some very spooky moments the one thing I
will say about this is that it has a
really good hook with the way that it
makes a normal house very creepy it does
this game is very good at that for all
the the criticisms that I could talk
about it's it's all like dwarfed by the
fact that if I don't mention the good
then why am I even mentioning the bad
the good is that it makes it scary and
at the end of the day so long as the
game is scary that's all that really
matters clunkiness like game mechanics
that I'm not 100 sure are clear or
whatever that it's still scary and if it
can cultivate a scare and make you
really fear for your life for a while
there wish it did which this game this
and all of these have all of these have
every one of these has and that's a good
game in my book and that's a thumbs up
for me so thank you everybody so much
for watching oh no
out